backend is huge and if we start
discussing every single component that
could be part of it we will be stuck
here for years so what we will do is we
will only discuss those topics which are
used in majority of the code bases let's
say 90% of them with that in mind let's
talk about HTTP protocol the medium
through which our browsers talk to our
servers either to send data or to
receive data from it and as I said there
are a lot of other ways and protocols
which clients and servers use to
communicate with each other and HTTP
being one of the most used ones we will
focus on that now there are two ideas
which are at the heart of HTTP protocol
the first one being tessness what does
it mean tessness basically means it has
no memory of past interactions so each
HTTP request carries all the necessary
information for the server to process it
such as headers or URLs and methods
which we will see in a bit and after the
server responds it forgets about the
request if a client makes another
request the server treats it as a new
and unrelated event and it also means
self-contained requests since the server
does not remember pass requests each
request must include all the necessary
data such as authentication tokens or
session information to handle that
specific interaction for example in the
case of accessing a user profile the
client has to provide credentials like
cookies or tokens on every request for
for the server to know which user is
requesting the data so what are the
benefits of that what are the benefits
of this stateless model the obvious one
being Simplicity stateless design
simplifies server architecture because
the server does not need to store
session information which would
otherwise require additional resources
and complexity and it also means
scalability stateless protocol makes it
easy to distribute request across
multiple servers because no single
server need needs to keep track of a
session and if the server crashes it
does not affect the state of a client
interaction as there is no session or
memory of a request that needs to be
restored and having said that because
HTTP is stateless developers often
Implement State management techniques
like cookies or sessions or tokens to
maintain continuity in interactions
where needed like user logins or
shopping cards and we'll explore those
soon in this series and the second idea
is client server model in a typical HTTP
request flow there is a client and there
is a server always the client typically
is a web browser or an application which
initiates the communication by sending a
request to the server the client is
responsible for for providing all
information needed by the server such as
the URL of the resource or the headers
and
everything and then there is a server
which hosts resources like websites or
apis or other content and waits for
incoming requests from the clients when
the server receives a request it
processes it and sends back the
appropriate response such as a web page
or data or error message or a Json file
or a text file or any other kind of
content now the thing to remember here
is HTTP protocol states that
communication is always initiated by the
client to get some kind of resp response
by the server and throughout our
discussion we can go ahead and safely
assume that HTTP and https are
interchangeable because https to
oversimplify it just a more secure
version of HTTP but the underlying
principles are the same with more
security features like encryption and
security certificates or TLS stuff like
that which boarders too much into the
network engineering domain also to send
some kind of request or receive some
kind of response first the client and
the server need to establish some kind
of connection mechanism right otherwise
how are they going to communicate what
is the medium of the communication and
for that sgtp uses TCP
TCP which is a protocol which is a
transmission protocol essentially HTTP
does not require the underlying
transport protocol to be connection
based it only requires it to be reliable
and not lose message messages at minimum
presenting an error in such cases and
among the two most common transport
protocols on the internet which are TCP
and UDP TCP is considered to be more
reliable HTTP therefore relies on the
TCP standard which is connection based
now this is called an OSI model which is
often referred when we are talking about
sending and receiving data over a
network right and we as backend
Engineers often deal with this layer the
top layer the layer 7even application
layer and so a lot of discussions for
example the recent one which we talked
about the TCP handshake and establishing
connections and TLS encryptions they
often border into these
layers so they are mostly network
engineering concepts of course it's it's
good to know about those but if we start
exploring those it'll be a rabbit hole
and we'll have to cover a lot of
Concepts right so what we'll do is we'll
focus on the application layer with a
brief about you know what happens in the
netor layer like as I said HTTP uses TCP
and TCP uses something like a 3-way
handshake which if you're curious about
you can just look up and study more on
that now throughout the years we had
different versions of HTTP which kept
redefining how clients and servers send
and receive data right in sttp 1.0 each
request opened a new connection this led
to inefficiencies since a connection had
to be established and closed for every
request and response which slowed
performance in HTTP 1.1 they introduced
something called as persistent
connections allowing multiple request
and responses over the same connection
over the same TCP connection that was
established before sending the request
which significantly improved performance
it also added stuff like chunk transfer
encoding and better caching mechanisms
in SCP 2.0 they introduced multiplexing
allowing multiple requests or responses
over a single collection it uses
something called binary framing instead
of text and supports header compression
with Edge pack or and server push
allowing servers to send resources
before the client requests them now in
sttp 3.0 built on quick protocol a
transport layer protocol over UDP right
instead of TCP it is designed over UDP
which improved performance with faster
connection establishment reduce latency
and better handling of packet loss it
also continues to support multiplexing
without head ofline blocking which is
still an issue in HTTP 2.0 now again
that's a rabbit hole if you get too much
into the network stuff all we need to
remember is that from all these
discussions that client and servers
established some kind of network
connection and messages are sent and
received that's all you need to remember
for now now that we mentioned message
let's look at what HTTP messages look
like request messages or response
messages a request message is basically
the one that is sent by the client and a
response message is the one that is
received by the client from the server
so this is what a request message looks
like in HTTP and this is what a response
message looks like I intentionally took
more complex messages which had more
parameters and so that we can cover
different different components one by
one so on a high level I'll just explain
what is what in this right this part
this is called a request method this is
the resource URL the one we are
requesting from the server this is the
HTTP version which says we are using
HTTP version 1.1 which is the currently
the most used one this is the host right
which is our
domain the front ends domain and these
are this all of these things these are
called headers right we will talk about
headers soon there will be a blank line
here after all the headers to signify
that the headers are over and body
starts this is called a request body
some information the client wants to
send to a server right and in the
response message again we have the HTTP
version have the status code and the
value of the status code which basically
means the status code 200 means okay
right and we have again some response
headers after that there is a blank line
and we have the response
body so let's talk about HTTP headers
first this is very important since it's
the major part of the request here and
the responses on a high level what we
can see is headers are basically key
value pairs key value pairs of different
different parameters that is sent over
request or received over a response that
is the first definition and the next
question is why do we need headers why
not send the all these values in the you
know the URL or we have this request
body here why send why create a
different section just for sending more
information or more met data about the
request or the response why create
another level of abstraction and in
order to understand that let's take a
real life example we send Parcels right
ciers and we receive them the address of
about the phone number of the recipient
and different details right the the
state the the PIN code and all of these
things do we keep it inside the package
or do we write it on top and we write it
on top why because the one who is taking
the parcel from the sender and to the
receiver they need to know different
informations in order to
successfully transmit the package
through different modes of transmission
and if we kept all those information
inside the parcel they have to open that
right and which does not make any sense
but just for the sake of the example
they have to open that and they have to
see who is the recipient again and again
so let's say another person wants to see
the address so again they have to open
that so keeping the metadata the address
and the information of the recipient on
top of the parel uh gives a quick way of
checking different metadata about the
package sdtp headers can be thought of
something like that but they have more
uses before we go into the use cases
let's see what are some different kinds
of headers that we see so as you can see
there are a lot of different types of
headers so can we categorize them can we
categorize them and different types of
headers so let's see the first category
can be request headers which are sent by
the client to the server to provide some
kind of information about the request
itself it could be user agent which
identifies what kind of client is that
it is a browser or it is a it is Postman
or it is some kind of server or it's a
mobile app we have authorization which
sends different credentials like bar
token to the server to identify the user
you have accept headers which provides
informations like what kind of content
we are expecting whether it is a Json
whether it is a text whether it is an
HTML file so request headers help server
understand the client's environment its
preferences and its capabilities then we
have General headers which are used in
both request and responses which have
some metadata about the message itself
for example the date of the message and
different caching mechanisms like no
cache or max age and the connection
information whether to keep it alive or
to close it so General header have some
kind of information about the request
message or the response message then we
have representation headers which
primarily deal with the representation
of the resource being transmitted
whether it could be a request body or a
response message the content type
describes the media type of the request
or the response it could be Json or it
could be HTML the content length describ
the size of the resource in bites the
content encoding specifies any encoding
like G or D flare then we have eag a
unique identifier which is mostly used
for caching so representation headers
provides information about the body of
the message or the response ensuring the
clients and servers know how to
interpret and process request or the
response then we have security headers
which are used to enhance the security
of the request and response by
controlling behaviors like content
loading cookies and encryption hsts
ensures that the client only
communicates with the server over https
preventing protocol downgrade attack
content security policy restricts the
sources from which content like
JavaScript or css and images can be
loaded helping prevent cross site
scripting attacks x-frame options
prevents the web page from being
embedded in iframe mitigating
clickjacking attack X content type
options ensures that the browser does
not try to guess the mime type of the
content preventing MIM type sniffing
attack that cookie with HTTP only or
secure Flags secures cookies by making
them inaccessible with JavaScript and
ensuring they are sent over https so
security headers helps protect the
client and server from a variety of
attacks by controlling how the browser
behaves with resources and enforcing
security policies now there are two
ideas that we see here while talking
about HTTP headers one is
extensibility HTTP is highly extensible
because headers can be easily added or
customized without altering the
underlying protocol
right we only have to add some kind of
metadata and the whole flow of the
interaction changes depending on that
now headers can be defined and used for
various purposes making HTTP adaptable
to new technologies and use cases for
instance security enhancements as we
just talked about headers like strict
Transport Security and Force Security
connections custom headers developers
can create custom headers like X custom
header for specific application for
their own use cases content negotiation
the accept and the accept language and
accept encoding headers allows servers
to serve different versions of the
content depending on the client's
preference so the next part is the idea
of remote control sgtp headers act as
kind of a remote control on the server
side they allow the client to send
instructions or preferences to the
server influencing how the server
responds or processes requests for
example content Ty negotiations clients
can request specific formats using
accept header and the server can respond
with the appropriate format if the
client says I want the HTML format the
server sends the HTML and if the client
says they want Json then the server
sends the Json format then caching and
expiration control the server can use
headers like cach control or expires to
control how long a resource should be
cached by the client then authentication
the client can authenticate itself to
the server through authorization header
influencing Access Control decisions
right so these provide more capabilities
on top of our messages which are very
useful in a lot of instances now we have
some kind of idea about the headers in
HTTP and we will explore them in more
depth when we are going through the
demos let's move on to the next
component of a HTTP message right the
HTTP method HTTP methods exist to
represent different kinds of actions
that a CL client like a browser or an
API consumer can request on a server
instead of every request doing the same
thing methods Define the
intent the keyword note here is the
intent the intent of the
interaction this gives clear semantic
meaning to each type of action and it is
pretty intuitive in that sense we use
get request to fetch some kind of data
from the server and it should not modify
anything on the server use post to
create some data in the server and post
request have a body which makes sense
because how else would you send the user
data to the server then we have
patch which is used to update some data
for example you have a users profile
page where they can update their name
and this also has a request body to send
the data to the server we also have put
which is also used to update data but
what sets it apart from patch is
whatever data that comes in request body
should completely replace the previous
instance basically patch can be thought
of as an append action or a selective
replacement while put is a complete
replacement even though a lot of times
developers use put when they should be
using patch and go against the semantics
so the thumb rule is always use patch
unless you have a specific use case for
put then we have delete method and as
the name suggests we use this to delete
some kind of resource from the server
and one prevalent idea that we have in
the context of HTTP methods is the idea
of EMP poent and nonm poent and what the
idea of important means is these HTTP
methods can be called multiple times and
we can expect the same kind of result
for example we generally consider the
methods get or put
or
delete in the category of it poent
methods because just think about it
you're trying to fetch some data from
the server right it does not matter how
many times you fetch it the data should
be same you should not be able to modify
any kind of data in the server so get is
obviously impotent and then we have put
because put completely replaces the
resource in the server so it does not
matter how many times you replace an old
with the new data it will the result
will be the same right so that is also
considered as important then we have
delete you can only delete a resource
from the server once because after that
it is already deleted you cannot perform
the action multiple times and expect
different results right the result will
always be the same the resource can only
be deleted once and then we have the
idea of nonmutant usually we consider
post request to be non important because
once you submit a request to create some
data let's
say uh a user can create a note using
your app right they submitted a post
request to create a new note and the
first time they submit the request the
request goes through the response is
successful and a new note is created and
when they do it a second time we create
a new note right there are two different
results for the same kind of request so
that's why we consider post to be a
non-idempotent method because it
produces different results for the same
kind of request after all the sgtp
methods we have one other method which
is called the options method and this
has a very interesting use case which is
used in the course flow right we
discussed this before in brief the
course flow which is part of the same
origin policy which browsers have now
options method this method you probably
won't use directly as a developer but
you will see them once in a while in
your browser network tab in pre-flight
requests so the options method is used
to fetch the capabilities of the server
for a cross origin request also known as
course which is used because browsers
have same origin policy which means by
default browsers follow the same origin
policy which restricts web pages from
making requests to a domain different
from theirs different from the one
serving the web page and course is a
security mechanism enforced by browsers
to control how web applications interact
with resources hosted on different
domains which are cross
origin and without course browsers block
the request made from a web application
running on one origin like example.com
to a different origin like API another
example.com for security reasons course
allows servers to specify who can access
their resources and how in a cross
origin request there are primarily two
types of flows one is a simple request
flow and another one is a pre-f flighter
request flow first let's look at the
simple request imagine our client our
frontend is at the Domain example.com
and our server is at the Domain api.
example.com and we make a get request
which looks something like like this
this is how the flow looks like the
client sends a request the browser
automatically adds the origin header to
indicate the origin of the request the
request uses a simple method which are
usually get post or head and then it
reaches the server the server checks for
the origin header against it C policy if
the origin is
allowed the server includes the access
control allow origin header in the
response and it sends the response
response the server responds with the
resource and includes the necessary
course headers for example Access
Control allow origin header and this is
what the response looks like it has the
appropriate course header which the
browser looks for while it passes the
response it sees that our domain which
is the example.com is different from the
host domain which is the api. another
domain.com and since these two are
different the browser checks whether the
server's response has this header or not
whether it responds with this particular
header Access Control allow origin if
the server responds with the domain of
the client example.com or it could also
respond with star which means allow all
Origins right if either of those two
conditions are true then the browser
lets the response go through to the
client to whatever the JavaScript client
requesting the resource and imagine
imagine if the response looked like this
the client sent the request the server
got the request and assuming the server
did not add the corresponding course
headers or assuming the server did not
allow this particular domain as the
client then what the server does it
excludes this particular header from the
response so the response looks something
like this and when the browser finally
parses it it sees that it sees the
absence of this header and what it does
it blocks the this particular response
from being passed you will get an error
in our console and we will see the error
in the network tab as a course error and
this is how a simple request flow looks
like next we have a pre-lighted request
flow for a cross origin request and how
does a browser distinguish between a
simple request flow and a pre-lighted
request flow so these are the three
conditions the browser checks before it
decides it has to do a PF flight request
which basically means it has to do a
request before the original request to
inquire some stuff to inquire some
capabilities and to let the server know
about some capabilities right and when
does a request qualify as a pre-lighted
request one is the method is not get
post or head example it is a put request
or a delete request and it is a either
or situation right it either of these
conditions have to be true then it will
be considered as a pre-lighted request
so the first condition is obviously it
has to be cross Surin request which
means our domain and the server domain
has to be different and the second
condition is one of these three and
after that it will be a c request and
inside that it will be a pre-lighted
request so the first condition is it has
to be either a put request or a delete
request or the request includes some
nons simple headers nons simple headers
are basically anything apart from our
general headers or request headers so
one example could be an authorization
header or some custom headers right and
the third one is or the request has a
content type other than application form
URL encoded or multiart or text plan
these are called General content types
or simple content types so if assuming
our application our client request the
data to be in Json
in that case it will be considered as a
pre-lighted request and if you are a
frontend engineer or a backend engineer
you know that mostly we deal with Json
data right so most of our requests are
considered as a pre-lighted requests
these are the three conditions either of
them have to be satisfied before we move
on before the browser moves on to make a
pre-flight request what does a
pre-flight request looks like this is
when we finally see the use of options
method right a pre-flight request is
made with an options method and pre-
flight request looks something like this
it has the method as options it has the
appropriate resource URL and the HTTP
version it has the host header which is
the header of our API the origin the
domain of the front end and this header
Access Control request method so it is
basically asking the server whether this
method is supported for this URL or not
so it is saying I am making a cross
origin request and do you support this
put method for this route right and it
also asks whether you support this
particular header or not if it is needed
and the browser sends the options
request to the server the request does
not include actual data right this does
not include any request body or anything
it is just a general inquiry to the
server about its capabilities and after
that if the server is is properly
handling course flow if the server
supports cross origin requests it
responds something like this and if the
server does not handle cost request then
it won't respond with this and the
request will be automatically blocked by
the browser and if it does handle it it
requests with something like this what
it says is this is the status code of
the response which means there is no
content this is just a general
information we use 204 when there is no
content then these are the four
important headers it responds with the
first one is the access control allow
origin it says yes I allow the client's
domain which is example.com as a cross
origin as a valid cross origin request
right it can either respond with this or
it can respond with a star which
basically means I allow all types of
clients to make request to me this is
the one valid condition it is browser
checks it the next is we asked whether
you allow put request for this resource
or not so the server says yes I allow
these two different kinds of methods it
is the put method and delete method for
this resource for this particular route
right and the browser checks it off the
next one is we asked whether you allow
authorization header and the server says
yes I allow authorization header and
then it is also checked off and the last
one is Access Control maxage what this
means is the server says don't make make
any more pre-flight request to me right
it says these these configs whatever I
responded with these will be the same
for at least the next 24 hours so you
don't have to keep making more
pre-flight requests for every route
before you send the original request so
this saves some bandwidth for both our
servers and clients so this is the
pre-flight request that the browser
makes and the server responds with the
appropriate headers the browser checks
off all these conditions and then the
browser sends the final request which is
the original request that the client
wanted to make and the server responds
according to the original request with
whatever the operations are required
this is how the typical course flow
looks like and now that we understood
the theory let let's look at a real demo
okay now before we start let me make
this clear that we won't be looking at
any code because as I said we are
learning from first principles and the
rule for that is
we try to understand the concepts first
how the underlying mechanism Works
before we dive into code before we
understand the how but first we have to
understand what for all these demos that
we are going to do in this video and and
all the other videos in this series we
won't be looking at any code it does not
matter what language the server is
written in what framework it is written
in I'll explain what I am changing in
the server what I have done in the
server for all it matters it can be
implemented in any language that's that
and this is a tool it's called burp suit
and it is used by ethical hackers if you
may it has a lot of features as you can
see but primarily what we are going to
use it for is HTTP intercepting or
visualizing HTTP traffic and it offers a
quite a nice set of features for that
with that what I have here is I have a
simple front end app again it could be
in any language and what I want to show
is one for our course flow one is the
simple request and one is the pre-light
request and how they look like in actual
browser environment so let's fire the
first simple
request okay so we got this response
that we are rendering here and let's
inspect the request and response for now
right if you go here this is what the
request and response looks like right we
already took a look at all these
components right the method and the URL
and all these headers and the response
the status code and the response headers
the response body so let's focus on the
course here what is the first parameter
for a request to be considered as a
cross origin request by the browser the
first thing is the origin so this is our
local host file
173 and the host right this is our apis
which is running on the port 3,000 of
Local Host since the host and the origin
are running on different ports in Local
Host by the browser this is considered
as a cross origin request and according
to the same origin policy we can only
make request from Local Host 5173 to
Local Host 5173 right since we not it is
considered as a cross origin request the
headers to focus here is origin header
let me minimize
this so the the headers to focus here is
the origin header which is our origin
the front end origin and the host the
domain or the port that you want to
connect to which is the apis right for
the request these are the two important
headers now let's go to the response now
the thing to f Focus here is this header
right as I had explained the browser
makes a cross origin request and when it
gets the response it checks whether it
has the access control allow origin
header or not or whether it has the
appropriate port or the domain so it has
the front ends Port right the
5173 or it could also have star so in
that case the browser lets the response
through and and it does not block it
since according to the core sets this
response is now expected right this
response is now allowed and now that's
why we are able to get the response and
now we are able to render it in our
front end right let's see what happens
if you remove this header like this
Access Control allow origin header from
the server for a simple request let me
just go and make this change okay I have
went ahead and made the change in the
server now it won't return the appri
corer Access Control allow origin Let me
refresh
this and let's clear this history so
that we can focus on the particular
request now let's fire the same request
again and before we do let's disable
caching so that we can see what a new
request looks like right so let me fire
this the browser blocked this response
right it says course error and why let's
inspect this request and response so
here if you see we have a cross origin
request because our origin is 5173 and
the host is 3001 and the server does not
return an access control allow origin
header right because we removed it and
for that reason the browser has blocked
the request because of course error so
this is how the simple request flow
looks like and now let's move on to our
pre-lighted request right okay I have
gone ahead and enabled the course again
so that we can test the pre-flight
request flow okay let me fire
this all right as you can see here the
first request that went through was the
options request right the pre-flight
request and then the original request
went through let's look at them one by
one how the whole flow looked like okay
for the pre-flight request as we have
already discussed the method was options
and it is a cross origin request because
the referrer and the origin are
different ports right and for
that what the server responded with it
responded with status code 204 no
content because it is just a general
inquiry right pre-flight requests are
General inquiries they don't have
request bodies or response bodies and
the server responded with Access Control
allow origin with the front ends domain
or Port right this makes the browser
allow the response wants to go through
that is the first condition and before
that let's see why a pre-flight request
was fired right why why this was not
considered a simple request he
investigate the original request what
was the conditions it is not a simple
method which is get post or head right
that is that was one of the conditions
so it is already satisfied but let's
look at others it also has a
authorization header that also counts it
out of a simple request right that is
the second one and the third one is the
content type is application Json and it
is sending a Json request body right all
the three conditions are satisfied but
even if one of them was satisfied it
would have still fired a pre-flight
request for this let's go back to our
options pre-light request analysis the
first one was it allowed the client's
domain so that the browser lets the
response to go through the second
one Access Control allowed methods so
the server says all these methods get
post put delete these methods are
allowed for the server it lets the
client know the capabilities of the
server the third thing is Access Control
allowed headers it says these are the
two headers which are not simple headers
that are supported by the server which
is the content type and authorization
since the client asked for them if you
look at this Access Control request
method put the client is asking with the
pre-flight request whether the put
method is allowed or not and whether the
these two headers authorization and
content type these two headers are
allowed or not so for that the server is
responding with these headers it says
get post put delete is allowed it also
says content type and authorization is
also allowed we have also set the max
age for the access control to zero for
testing purposes right because if you
cach this for let's say 5 minutes then
pre-flight request be fired that's why
this is used for and the content length
is zero because there is no content
since the pre-flight request was
successful it returned 204 it is a
success status code the browser let the
response go through and it fired the
original request it is the put method
and this is the original request it has
put method the resource URL the origin
and the authorization header the host
the request body and it responded with a
response body right and that's how the
pre-flight request flow looks like so
the simple request and the pre-flight
request flow combined they make the
whole course flow and this is all you
have to understand how course Works
behind the scenes and why these headers
are important and how browsers react to
them okay moving on the next component
that I want to cover is response codes
this part this 200 okay what are these
and why are they needed HTTP response
codes exist to communicate the result of
a request in a standardized way know you
can just look at the response code and
see whether the request was successful
or not or what is the state of the
server without looking into the body or
without judging from the response
message that okay so if the request was
successful then I would have expected
this structure if the request was
unsuccessful then I would have expected
this structure if the server crashed
then I would have expected a null object
right we don't have to make those
decisions we can judge by these status
Cotes so they quickly inform the client
whether the request was successful
resulted in an error or requires further
action they also help clients handle
errors by providing specific codes to
identify the problem for example
unauthorized access will return 401 so
now the clients can check whether it is
40 one and it can log the user out
saying you have to log in again right
those kinds of actions they can be
judged with response codes or imagine
let's say it was a bad request error
because of some invalid value through a
form submission then the client can ask
their user to make changes to their form
submission and resubmit right depending
on those status code which was like 400
also standardization HTTP response codes
are standardized across all web services
enabling consistency in how servers
communicate with different clients
regardless of the platform or language
used it does not matter whether you are
making a server in python or golang or
rust or JavaScript or Ruby you have to
follow this standard if the request was
successful you have to return to 200 if
the if you created something you have to
return to1 these are the standards and
you have to follow them now before HTTP
status course clients would have to
guess the outcome of a request based on
the content of the response as I said
leading to inconsistencies and
inefficiencies HTTP status code solve
this by providing a universal language
that all clients and servers understand
streamlining interactions and error
handling on a high level response codes
are three-digit numbers they could
either start with 1 2 3 4 or five and
depending on the starting digit we
categorize them as different level of
errors or different types of errors on a
high level
the digits starting with one are
informational responses two are success
responses three are redirection five are
server errors four are client errors
response codes starting with one this
code is sent by the server to indicate
that it has received the headers and the
client can proceed to send the request
body and when is it used commonly used
in large uploads the client sends the
headers first and if the server is okay
with the request it sends a 100 Contin
so the client can send and the rest of
the body also there is which is which is
used for switching protocols right we
have a use case for that this indicates
that the server is switching protocols
as requested by the client such as
upgrading from HTTP to websocket this is
not the mostly used response codes that
you will encounter on your day-to-day
life so let's focus on these four which
you'll see a lot of times especially 2 4
and 5 200 series as you know are used
for success responses and under that we
have three mostly used ones one is
200 and
2011 and 204 200 is the most common code
it indicates that the request was
successful and the server is returning
the requested resource or performing the
requested action for example successful
get request where a resource is
retrieved
2011 it indicates that the request has
been fulfilled and resulted in a
creation of a new resource for example
post request or new form submissions
that's where servers use this response
to indicate that the a new resource has
been
created then we have 204 that we just
saw in a course flow when we send
options request a pre-flight request and
the server responds with 204 saying that
there is no content but these are the
information in the form of headers this
also indicates that the request was
successful but there is no content we
also sometimes use it for delete delete
request right the client makes a delete
request you delete the particular
resource but the server says okay I've
deleted it but there is no content to
return right you can just assume that
the request was successful then we have
300 and in 300 the mostly used ones are
302 and
304 301 means moved
permanently which means the requested
resource has been permanently moved to a
new UR URL and the future request should
use this new URL for example let's say
initially you had a route called
user and eventually you decided to move
that route to slash person so in order
to maintain backwards compatibility so
that old users or old applications that
are still using this route don't break
what you do is you add a 301 response
for this routes and read direct then to
the/ person route so it is a permanent
redirect the next one is 302 which means
temporary redirect the requested
resource is temporarily located at a
different URL but the client should
continue to use the original URL for
future request so when do we use this
let's imagine you are running a campaign
or something and for those couple of
hours you want to redir redirect a
particular route to a new route for
catching new traffic or showing a
different UI or something like that but
you don't want to stick to that right
you want to revert the changes so you
want to say to the client that for for
now I'm making a redirect but later on
you should use the original route only
and then we have
34 which says not modified it indicates
that the resource has not been modified
since the last time the client requested
it and this we will see soon in a bit in
a uh when we explore our caching demo
and when do we use it this is mostly
used in conjunction with conditional get
request to allow efficient caching right
when we are using e tax to let the
client know that the uh response is not
modified it should use the cached one
only instead of downloading the new
response so it just says that it is not
modified so you should keep using your
old response the cach response then we
have the 400 series errors and as a
backend engineer I think you will mostly
deal with these errors because these are
the client errors or errors that are
triggered because of something some
behavior from client so let's see what
are the common ones the first one is
400 and what this means is it says bad
request and when does it Trigger or when
should we fire it for example when the
client sends invalid data or illogical
data or something related to data right
for example you are expecting a number
and the client sends an array or a
string right you are expecting an email
but the client sends a phone number
something like that it's a bad request
that's what it says and you're letting
the client know that there is something
wrong with your request format so fix it
and make a new request the next one is
401 which is which means unauthorized
when should you fire this when a request
requires authentication but the client
has either failed to provide valid
credentials or is not authenticated at
all so let's say you are expecting a JWT
token and either if the JWT token has
expired or if the client has not send
the token in the first place so in those
scenarios you want to say that you are
unauthorized that's when you respond
with this status code 401 next up we
have
403 and it says forbidden which means
the server understood the request but it
refuses to authorize and this can happen
even if the client is authenticated for
example when a user tries to access a
resource they don't have permission to
access so let's say you are user a and
you are trying to delete a resource of
user B so that's when the server says
you don't have the necessary permissions
to perform this action so you are
forbidden 403 next up we have 404 and it
means not found I think this is the most
famous status code 404 this is fired
when the client requests a resource that
is unavailable
either because the URL is incorrect or
the resource has been deleted so in
those cases the service is 404 it is not
found then we have 405 which means
method not allowed when does it get
fired when an invalid HTTP method is use
such as trying to put to a resource that
only accepts get or post this often
happens because of typos right we are
working on front end and instead of
doing a put request we do a patch
request or instead of doing a post
request we do a put request so in those
scenarios server says 405 which means
method not allowed then we have
409 which means conflict this has a
number of use cases one of which we can
imagine is let's say in your app you are
allowing users to create folders right
and the condition is the folder names
has to be unique they cannot create two
folders with the same name when they try
to create a new folder when they submit
a post request you check whether the
folder is already existing or not if it
is you can respond with this error 409
conflict so the client will understand
that a folder with that name already
exists and it should try with a new
folder name right it means conflict and
at last we have 4 to9 which means too
many requests and this is mostly used
when we are trying to rate limit uh the
client's request rate limit basically
means if client tries to make too many
requests in a particular interval let's
say in your server you have configured
it to allow at most 60 requests for a
client in 1 second and if the client
tries to exceed that you can respond
with this response code which ISS 429
too many requests okay let's move on to
the 500 series and we have the most
famous one which is the 500 which means
internal server error this is often used
for unexpected conditions in server
something some process broke or some
exceptions were raised which were not
handled in the server so something
unexpected happened at the server so
instead of you know just returning a
empty response or just breaking or
hanging the request we respond with 500
internal server errors the client knows
that something went wrong with the
server then we have 501 which means not
implemented for example example when the
server does not support the requested
HTTP method or functionality but it
plans to edit soon so that's when we add
a 501 which means currently it is not
supported it might be in the future
right so we are trying to get that
intention through to the client so that
it is not implemented yet then we have
502 right it means bad gateway we
usually see this in Proxes like NX it
means when a server acts as a proxy like
in a load balance system or reverse
proxy and Upstream server returns an
invalid response so that's when 52 is
returned this is not something we uh
return intentionally this is handled
mostly by Proxes and load balancers then
we have
503s which means service unavailable
when the service is down when the
service is temporarily unable to handle
the request such as during high traffic
or when it is going maintenance so
that's when you return 503 to let the
client know that the service is
unavailable right now and it should try
again later at last we have
504 which means gway time out it is
similar to 502 but this specifically
means that the Upstream server failed to
respond within timeout period let's say
you have you're using enginex and
enginex could not get a response from
our original server which is running
behind it so that's when ninx responds
with 504 Gateway timeout that it did not
receive any response from our original
server that's why it says timeout okay
that's all that's pretty much all the
response codes you need to know to work
with
95% of use cases now in order to
solidify our understanding let's look at
a quick demo where we look at some of
these responses okay now again we have a
friend end app for this demo where we
are trying to emulate some of the
response resp CES and there is a server
running which will respond with
different status codes right okay so
what we'll do is let's just fire all of
these requests then we will examine what
the responses look
like so let me go
ahead
and
okay
created this one one
all right we have fired all these
requests let's go through one by one so
as you can see we have all these options
request before each original request
because because these are cross original
requests the browser need to do
pre-flight request to support those
let's go through all the original
requests one by one to see what are the
responses looks like okay the first one
was 200 okay as I said this is a
successful respon
which means request was successful right
the status code is 200 and the next one
is a post request which says 2011 which
means created and This Server response
even though it is a mock request and a
mock response this is what usually it
looks like the resource was created
successfully and and the status code is
2011 then we have 401 bad request says
bad request missing required
data then we have have then we have 401
which means unauthorized which which
typically means either you have not
included the token the JWT token or the
cookie or whatever authentication
mechanism you're using whether you are
not you have not included that or even
if you have it has expired or it is not
valid anymore next we have forbidden
which means you're trying to perform
some action which are not authorized to
do right that's why it says 40 through
forbidden you do not have access next up
we have 404 which means not found and
the server says something like not found
the requested resource could not be
found next we have 409 conflict which is
resource already exists so this could
happen when as our previous example
maybe you already have a folder and
you're trying to create a folder with
with the same name again so that's why
the server says resource already exists
right then we have internal server
error which is 500 and the server just
says internal server error without
letting the client know too much of the
information for security reasons then we
have 503 service unavailable please try
again later right that's pretty much
covers most of the status Cotes that we
have discussed and that we saw in this
demo okay moving on let's explore
another interesting concept HTTP caching
what does http caching mean HTTP caching
is a technique to store copies of
responses for reuse reducing the need to
repeated request to the server this
improves load time reduces uh bandwidth
and decreases server load right because
the client does not need to download a
lot of data and the server does not need
to send a lot of data if the data is not
changed this client can just reuse the
old data right that's what caching means
reusing the old data if the data is not
changed in order to understand this
let's just go through a demo instead of
of going it theoretically how it looks
like practically in a browser
environment okay let's go to the request
cycle and understand how caching works
by following the trail let let me just
do a refresh so when we first render the
page we are doing a fetch operation so
let's start from there okay we fired all
these requests and what you want is the
last one right because these are just uh
JavaScript files and CSS and stuff okay
okay what happened in the last request
Let's see we did a get request to this
endpoint API resource and there is
nothing else in the request headers that
we should focus on right now right let
come let's come to the response what did
the server respond with the first
important thing is this one cache
control what it says is you should
maintain the cash for this resource for
maximum 10 seconds right this is the
first important header the next is e tag
e tag is basically a hash so for the
sake of this example we are using a
random number but eags are usually
hashes which are computed from a
response for example the server might
have taken this response hashed it and
sent us that hash in the form of E tag
right and we will see what is the use of
that in the next request the next
important header is last modified with
this what the server is trying to say is
this is the last time this request was
modified and judging from this time and
date we can decide whether we should use
the old resource the cash resource or
request for a new one these are the
three important headers that we are
going to use for caching okay so that is
the initial request and in this request
the server responded with a 200 along
with the requested resource whatever
that is we won't focus on that we are
just seeing there is a response body all
right what happens when we do a fetch
operation for the same resource right
let's do a
fetch okay what happened here let's look
at the response let's focus on the
request first we are again doing a get
request to this end point and now the
headers to focus in the request is this
these two headers if none match and if
modified since what we are trying to say
to the server is if the E tag the hashed
version of the response object the E tag
of the requested resource is not the
same as this one which we have with us
in the browser or if the request has
been modified after this which means we
have the outdated version right we are
saying if the eag does not match or if
the request has been modified after this
then send us a new resource then send us
the updated resource otherwise I will
just use my cach version which I have
with me in the browser cache and to that
what server says is it responds with 304
not modified and we just talked about
different response codes right and 304
meant the requested resource has not
been modified ever since what the server
did was it checked the if none match
header which is which is the eag and it
also checked the last modified and since
the resource matched either the eag or
the last modified it send the client a
304 response which means the requested
resource has not been modified ever
since from the last time you fetched it
so you can use you can go ahead and use
your cast version let's update the
resource for now let's clear
this and let's fire an update
resource okay what what happened here
let's explore the first request okay
ideally we should have done a patch
request or put request but for the sake
of this example again we just fired a
request a post request okay we updated
the resource and the server responded
with 200 okay and it also sent us a new
e tag right 2943 and after that the
client did a new get request in this as
you can see the client sent the old dag
which which was 3141 our cast version so
client did a get request with the old
eag and the last modified sense to the
server and the server responded with 200
instead of 304 because the resource has
been modified after that right because
we did a update resource request and the
server responded with 2943 which is the
updated e tag the last modified Etc and
let's go ahead again do a fet
request okay and what do we have here we
are again using the eag that was just
provided by the server in this request
right this was 200 and the server
provided as with a new e tag we are
using that e tag and the last modified
value and we are doing another get
request so the server checked it again
and since it is the latest version of
the resource it again responded with 304
for not modified so this is how you
handle caching using the HTTP protocol
using different headers in server and
client even though in a production
setting it gets a lot complicated
because the server has to manually
Implement and manage all these e tags
and if by mistake forgot to update an e
tag right then the client will continue
to use the cast version with the
outdated resource which is not a good
idea nowadays we have better Solutions
for caching right for example react
query which is a complete client side
caching so the client has the complete
power over when it wants to use a cach
resource and when it wants to refetch
right at what interval and all these
powerful capabilities which is in my
opinion a much better solution compared
to the traditional HTTP based caching
but it is good to know that we have this
option if our use cases simple enough
then we can go ahead and use HTTP based
caching moving on another important
topic that usually comes up in client
server model in HTTP is content
negotiation we already looked at some of
these headers for example accept the
content type application gson Etc so
this is an important topic to understand
how clients and servers exchange
information about different types and
and coding and representation of the
content this is basically a mechanism
using which client and server agree on
the best format to exchange data the
client can indicate its preferred format
like Json or XML or HTML and the server
will try to respond with a compatible
format or if not available a fallback
format that is the whole idea to look at
a high level we have generally three
types of content negotiation one is a
med type which means the client
specifies the desired format through the
accept header which is application Json
or XML then we have the language
negotiation the client requests content
in a specific language using the accept
language header uh it could be English
or Spanish then we have encoding
negotiation right the client specifies
which encoding it supports using the
accept encoding header like gz or
deflate and the server responds with
that compression format we have a topic
which is HTTP compression which is also
part of this topic only so we will
quickly see that also in the demo that's
the whole idea and let's just jump into
the demo to understand how it works and
again there is a server running which
will help us understand different types
of content negotiation and this is a
frontend client through which we will
communicate with our server so let's
just try out different types of requests
and we'll see how the headers differ and
how the responses differ depending on
the types of headers the client is
sending okay let's first just try the
default one which is which is a language
is English the format is Json and the
preferred encoding is jip so let's do F
FD source and this is what the request
and response looks like okay so it was a
get request to this
endpoint and what we said is the
language we are saying is English we are
sending that information using the
accept language header that we prefer
the English language then what we are
saying is the format is Json right we
send that with accept application Json
and there is the encoding header right
that we are saying accept encoding the
browser supports these kinds of
encodings right JZ defl VR and zsd so we
said we are expecting English and in
Json format so this how this is how the
server responded it it is sending us a
Json
and it is in English so let's trve one
thing let's make it to Spanish and see
how the response
differs I made it Spanish and add did
another
fetch okay so let's see how this differs
in this the only thing that changed was
instead of accept language English in
the header the client said accepted
language is Spanish so depending on on
that the server was able to update the
response so instead of sending it in
English since the client prefers Spanish
the server responded with Spanish and
what if we change the format from Json
to XML and we do a
Fetch and we look at this what change
here we are saying we accepted format is
XML and the accepted language is Spanish
this is the XML format and the language
is Spanish and on a high level this
these are the benefits of using content
negotiation based headers right the
client can let the server know what are
its preferences whether it is the data
format or the language of the data and
depending on that the server can decide
to send according to that format it can
make the life of the client Easier by
sticking to the preferences those are
the primarily two type of content
negotiations while we are discussing
content negotiation there is one
interesting topic which falls under the
same umbrella which is HTTP based
compression it could be either gzip
deflate or other formats right so let's
look at why do we need compression and
how does it work so now what I've done
is I've gone ahead and replace the Json
response with a very large file file of
11,000 entries now let's file the
request okay this is the response
response and the size is 3.8 M since
it's a very large file and let's look
how the response looks
like this is what it looks like because
we are compressing the file on the
server side with gzip encoding right
here it says content encoding is gzip
because the client says it accepts
encoding of gzip one of the encoding
formats now why do we use it to show
that let me just go and disable
compression in the server side okay and
now that I have disabled the compression
let's fire the same request
again and as you can see the significant
increase in the size it's the same file
right it's the same file with 11,000
entries and because we are using
compression the file size was 3.8 MB and
now that we have disabled it the file
size becomes 26 M that's a huge increase
in size and imagine every client having
to download that file it it it caes a
lot of based of bandwidth and that is
why we need compression so that if the
response size is very large we can
compress it to a format and on the
client side the browser can decompress
it and it will get the same response and
this is another important topic which we
won't really work with it's good to know
that it exists behind the scenes in the
early days of HTTP specifically HTTP 1.0
each request response cycle required a
separate connection to the server now
this created inefficiencies since
establishing and closing TCP connections
is resource intensive and slow to
address this persistent connections were
introduced in HTTP 1.1 now with
persistent connections a single TCP
connection can be reused for for
multiple requests and responses avoiding
the overhead of opening and closing a
collection for every interaction and for
achieving that they introduced this
header called keep alive keep alive is
the mechanism that enables persistent
connections it allows the client and
server to reuse the same connection for
multiple request responses until one of
them decides to close it so what are
some key points to remember here in sttp
1.1 connections are persistent by
default we won't have to do anything
explicitly about them meaning they
remain open for further requests unless
explicitly closed and multiple SB
request and responses can be sent over a
single connection this reduces latency
and saves resources as fewer connection
need to be established now the second
thing is the keep alive header while
persistent connections are default in
HTTP 1.1 the connection keep alive
header is it's still sometimes used to
explicitly ask the server to keep the
connection open this header can also
include option like how long the
connection should remain open with a
timeout or how many requests can be sent
before the connection is closed with the
max value now the third thing is when
connection is set to close and when that
is specified the connection is closed
after the response is sent this is the
behavior in HTTP 1.0 by default and it
can still explicitly enforced in HTTP
1.1 that is some amount of information
you just have to understand but you
usually won't be working with them the
default values work fine one last topic
that I want to cover is handling large
request and responses how server takes
in large request like Files video files
image files audio files any kind of file
which are very large compared to our
typical Json and how client can receive
large responses in the same way so let's
just jump into the demo and see how it
usually works now here we have two
examples in one we will see how clients
can send large request to the server and
in the second one we'll see how servers
can send large responses to the client
first one is multiart request multiart
is usually used for sending large files
or any kind of files to the server from
the client and the difference between
our typical Json request body is in
multiart request the file the data of
the file the binary data is transferred
to the server in Parts in different
parts that's why it is called multiart
request so let's see how it looks like I
have selected a picture and let's click
on upload
file now let's look at the response of
this here is what the request looks like
it is a post request and we are
specifying a Content length and our
content type is multiart form data and
this is the important part the boundary
and why we need this is since our binary
data the binary data of the file is
transferred in parts we want to specify
what is going to be the delimit what
will separate the parts right we need
some kind of code that will separate the
parts so we are saying this will be our
delimiter and if we do a search
here we have the delimeter at the start
of the binary data and the next
occurrence
is at the end of it when the all the
binary data ends in the request body
right that is the use of the boundary
parameter and that is how we transfer a
large file to the server and the server
can read the file responds with the some
details of the file in order to say that
the upload was successful the idea is
whenever we want to transfer large files
to the server we should use multiart
requests okay now the second thing is
receiving large responses from the
server for this demo I have used a large
text file in the server side and we want
to stream the data to the client side in
chunks that's what we want to do so
let's start the so let's start the
request and see how it looks like
click on stream
data so as you can see this is the first
chunk okay so if you go
here you can see that we are receiving
chunks continuously from the server in
different different requests so the
request is pretty much a normal request
it is a get request let's look at the
response what the response looks like
these are the three important things
that we have to to consider one is
content type it is saying that it is not
a text content right it is a text event
stream which says it will stream the
data to the client through different
events and the second one is the
connection keep alive it says keep the
connection alive until all the data is
sent and if is here we are still
receiving the chunks and we can keep
scrolling and scrolling and until the
file is completely transferred the
server will keep sending the data in
chunks and how does it work because of
these headers the content type text
event stream and the connection keep
live right and the client keeps
appending all the data that it is
receiving from the server and
constructing this whole text file and
that is how we transfer a large file
from a server to the client using chunk
transfer or text event stream and the
last thing before we end this lesson I
just want to give a brief idea about
what these terms mean SSL or TLS or
https even though we don't explicitly
work with them it's good to know what
are these SSL was the original protocol
for securing Communications between
client like a web browser and server it
encrypts data so that the sensitive
information like passwords or credit
card numbers cannot be intercepted by
attackers right it was the original
encryption mechanism between clients and
server now currently SSL is outdated due
to some some security vulnerabilities
and has been replaced by TLS so this is
the modern version of the encryption
that client and servers use for data
transmission TLS is a modern and more
secure version of SSL it encrypts data
in transit ensuring that any data sent
between the client and server is
protected from interception and
tampering how it works is TLS uses
certificates to authenticate the server
and establish an encrypted connection
preventing Eve dropping and data bries
TLS is continuously updated with newer
versions offering better security the
current recommended version is TLS 1.
and what is https then https is
basically HTTP but more secutive
features which is which are provided by
SSL or TLS initially it was SSL and now
it is TLS the underlying mechanism is
TLS and https is the one which uses TLS
how it works is when you visit a website
using
https TLS encrypts the communication
between your browser and the server this
protects sensitive data like login
credentials from being intercepted by
the attackers and that much information
is more than enough on this topic that's
all you need to know about TLS and sdps
to work on application Level great we
talked about a lot of stuff I hope
you're able to digest that and I hope
you rewatch some of the sections so that
you are able to internalize all of them
and overally this is all you need to
know about HTTP at least of course there
are more stuff to read if you want on
HTTP or TLS or PCP protocol different
different components of HTTP but in
order to work on backend systems if you
understand this much if you internalize
this much and you can visualize the
whole flow of all the the components
that we talked about today then you're
good to go you'll be able to understand
all you need to understand and you'll be
able to debug most of the stuff now that
you understand how the system works
behind the scenes and what are the
components that come into play in
different different flows that's all
about http